c'est effectivement le grand argument de
monseigneur lefebvre de l'institut saint
pie 10 et de tous les traditionalistes
qui considèrent que le monde a commencé
le monde catholique a commencé à
s'effondrer au moment en deux bâtiments
de en fait les travaux des historiens
montre que non que les églises ont
commencé à se vider bien avant et qu'il
s'agit d'un mouvement de sécularisation
qui date en gros du début du 19e siècle
et en gros de la rue mme des lumières
qui ont précédé la révolution française
et puis ce vaste mouvement
d'autonomisation de la pensée humaine
qui aujourd'hui abouti à une
sécularisation très très forte et qui
fait que aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'européens notamment ne voit plus de
raison d'être simplement à la foi
catholique
et puis vous pouvez rajouter à ça une
rupture essentielle fondamentale est
très importante dans la transmission qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui la culture
catholique fait partie du passé
je discutais récemment encore avec avec
des évêques français qui conseille qui
était absolument étonné de voir que même
leur propre neveu ou petit neveu ne
connaissez même plus les mots de base de
la foi catholique aujourd'hui donc ce
mouvement est ancien ce mouvement est
fondé sur toute une toute une évolution
alors maintenant effectivement le
concile vatican 2 certains vous disent
que ce concile n'a pas été mis en oeuvre
jusqu'au bout et que notamment
il prévoyait de donner du pouvoir aux
conférences épiscopales il prévoyait de
donner du pouvoir aux assemblées
paroissiales locales et qu' on n'est pas
allé jusqu'au bout qu'on n'a pas donné
de pouvoir aux laïcs et que notamment
durant les dernières années de jean paul
2 et durant le pontificat de benoît 16
et bien on a procédé à la scea la
sélection et la formation de prêtres qui
ont des profils qui sont des profils
anciens et qui est pour lesquels il
n'est pas question de partager le
pouvoir
mais là dessus françois est inflexible
notamment parce que françois a été
profondément ébranlée par la crise des
abus sexuels
[Musique]